- So I put myself in a position
where I could get a record deal.
Where I could find somebody.
Where I could call somebody.
Where I could say,
"Can I borrow you for a five minutes?"
- Lemme interrupt, I apologize.
- That's the name of the show.
- Thank you very much!
(hard rock music)
- Everybody, it's Gary again.
Back with another episode of my new show
that I'm super excited about called
Interrupted by Gary Vee.
Today's guest is Jesse
Itzler, an entrepreneur,
but I'm gonna let him frame it up for you
and then I'm gonna fire away
with a bunch of questions.
But first and foremost,
Jess, thanks for being on.
- Thanks for having me,
I quite appreciate it.
- So, tell the VaynerNation
that's listening right now
who you are.
- Great, well, I'm a serial entrepreneur.
I started out in the music business.
I was signed to a record label called
Delicious Vinyl in the 90's--
- What year did you sign?
- I signed in 1990, I was 21.
- And what kind of artist were you?
- Don't laugh.
I was a rapper.
- I'm not laughing!
(audience laughs)
- And I was a white
rapper, believe it or not!
- I'm aware, I can see it.
For everybody who's listening,
you'll hear some laughs in the background,
and things of that nature,
we're here in an off-site
kind of conference thing,
so we're just recording the podcast
in between sessions, so
keep going, Jess.
So you were a rapper at 21?
- Started out right--
- Where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in Long Island.
And then I went to a
school in Washington, D.C.,
at American University.
Got a record deal--
- Smart kid.
- Good test-taker, maybe, I
don't know about smart, but.
- Fair enough.
- Got a record deal right out of college,
after a lot of rejection.
Signed to Delicious Vinyl,
got dropped from the label a year later.
- Why?
- Sales and just wasn't the
right thing and tough timing,
I was behind Vanilla Ice
and I wasn't nearly as good as Eminem.
(laughs) Here I am.
But it was the best thing
that ever happened to me.
The worst thing at the time,
'cause I only had two things
on my resume after that.
I was a kiddie pool
attendant and I was a rapper.
And that's not gonna
get you a lot of jobs.
- How did the rapper thing go down?
How old are you?
- I'm gonna be 52.
- Hey, you look great.
So 52, so you're eight
years older than me.
So when does rap hit your radar?
- Rap hits my radar right away, man.
Right when it came on the scene.
I was probably, I don't know,
16, 15, so early eighties.
I heard "It's Like That" by Run-DMC,
"Sucker MCs" by Run-DMC,
fell in love with it.
Grew up in Long Island where
hip hop was emerging fast,
and just got the bug.
So started out breakdancing,
started out, you know, just
doing whatever I could do.
This a different era, you know.
Mid-eighties.
- I remember it.
- And just got into it.
And when everybody in
college was making resumes
and sending resumes to companies,
I'm like, "I'm getting a record deal!
I don't need a resume!"
And at that time I'd never
been in a studio, I--
- Were you an entrepreneurial kid?
- I was an insane kid.
I tried everything.
My parents gave me a long leash.
And I just tried anything
and they allowed me
and supported me to do anything like that.
But I wouldn't say I was
a sharp entrepreneur,
I didn't have a paper route,
- Right.
- No, but was just, I was exploring--
- You were not looking to make money?
- I was looking for adventure, man.
I was looking for fun, and I still am.
But I was never really
wired to make money.
- So what did your crew look like?
Were you like a skateboard kid too?
- I was athletic.
- Okay.
- I was artistic, I
was a good storyteller.
And I wasn't scared.
I wasn't scared to fail.
- Why?
- I wasn't scared to try.
'Cause my parents really
just supported my effort,
they praised my effort
and not the results.
And--
- Did they acknowledge when you failed?
- They praised the effort.
So if we got blown out
of a basketball game,
or if I had a great game or a bad game,
it was like, "You tried so hard."
And they've always praised the effort.
And as a father of four,
that's something that we do with our kids,
it's all about the effort.
- Where do you the Mendoza line is on
praising effort and making
one appreciate process,
versus creating delusion when
one is not good at that thing?
- Well, I think that the fine line
in between those two
points is disappointment,
and I think disappointment's
been stripped from kids.
- I agree.
- There's participation
trophies, and you get,
you know, everyone's on,
you know, you can make the--
- So your parents on the way home
of losing a game 42 to 16 were like,
hey, I really appreciate the fact that
you were down by 30,
that you were going hard,
but in the same token,
they weren't making excuses
or saying you're gonna be
Michael fuckin' Jordan.
- Yeah, but my dad owned a
plumbing supply house, man.
My dad didn't even get that deep into it.
It was like, he took me to the game,
he watched it, and then he went
and he sold plumbing supplies, like--
- Did he talk?
- Of course he talked!
But it wasn't about raising this kid
that's gonna go to Harvard or that's gonna
be an amazing athlete,
it was like letting me--
- So, you went hard,
and you get in the car,
and he says, "Good job, kid?"
- He says, "How'd you feel about it?"
You know?
- That's a really good one.
- Yeah.
- I like that.
- And then I say, "I feel
terrible, we got blown out."
- Right.
- And then he'd say like,
"Well you know, you did
great, and keep trying,"
and that kind of stuff.
My father wasn't the kind of person to
put any kind of pressure on me to succeed.
He was a family guy, he still is,
and it was just about that.
- And mom?
- Teacher and then raised four kids.
- And what was she saying to you?
- Same thing, it was just--
- Did she tell you, "You
look so cute in your shorts?"
Like was she that kind of mom?
My mom was!
She was like, "You looked great too."
I was like, "Thanks, Mom!"
I think I was 16 when I first realized,
wait a minute, I'm not the
best-looking person on Earth?
Like, you know?
Was she that kind of mom?
- She was, they really
gave me my distance.
And they let me figure it out--
- What number were you in the kids?
- I was the bottom, four.
- (laughs) Got it.
It's cool though!
- It's very cool.
- It is cool!
Like they've been
through enough reps where
I'm sure you're, is it a sister
or brother that's the oldest?
- Brother.
- Had it, slightly different.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
It was the best kind of
childhood for me though, man.
There was no, I didn't feel
any pressure to have to,
it was, you know what they did?
They put the pressure on me.
They made me--
- By not putting the pressure--
- They made me want it for me.
It can't be my parents' dream,
it would have had to be my dream.
- I get it.
- And they never, I remember
when I wanted to get
good grades for my
parents, my grades sucked.
When I was, I want to get good grades,
so I could get to a good school
for me, they skyrocketed.
So they took the pressure
off of me wanting--
- The freedom created the results.
- It was my goal!
It was my dream!
- So now, you get signed,
tell them about the New York Knicks song.
- I get signed to this label
called Delicious Vinyl,
I wrote a couple songs for
an artist named Tone Loc,
I get dropped from the label a year later,
I move back to New York City,
I have two things on my resume,
I was a kiddie pool
attendant, and I was a rapper.
And, but
my wife always says, this is so true,
you find your passion
at the intersection of
what it is you love to do
and what you're good at,
and providing a product
that people like or enjoy,
I love sports and music,
so I married those two things
and I wrote a theme song
for the New York Knicks, it
was called "Go, New York, Go,"
I was 22,
and the Knicks paid me
$4,000 for the song,
it cost me $4,800 to do the song,
you asked me if I was into money.
Not really, I lost $800
on my first big trade.
But the reality is, I
would have paid the Knicks
10 grand to do this song,
and the song became the number one
most requested song on New York radio, and
that took off--
- As a 44 year old Knicks fan,
you can't imagine what
that song actually is.
It was being played while
the Knicks made a run
and actually got to the NBA finals,
lost unfortunately in seven games
to the Rockets, but
I probably heard that song
8,000 times, 7,800 of them
were in a four-week period in 1994.
(laughter)
- Yes.
- It was insane.
- It was insane, and--
- That became your, tell
me living that moment,
where June, 1994, you're
eight years older than me,
so you're 22, right?
22, 23,
are you basically, you know,
the internet's not around,
so people don't know shit
the same way, are you
just walking around life,
and before you even say
hi, you telling people
that you wrote that fuckin' song?
I would be.
- Yeah, well.
(laughter)
It was interesting, 'cause
at that point of my life,
I slept on 18 different couches.
- [Gary] Yep.
- So I had 18 different
friends, I bounced around
for a week here at a
couch, couch, couch, couch,
and then all of a sudden,
I wrote this song,
and it's the number one
song, you know, at the time,
during the, it was big.
And--
- [Gary] Big big.
In New York, uncomfortably big.
- Yeah.
And I didn't really know how
to handle that, you know?
But everyone was asking
me for playoff tickets.
(laughter)
And I had no money, I
was sleeping on couches,
and you know what I did?
I got everybody playoff tickets.
- [Gary] That's cool.
- Yeah, on my credit card.
And I realized at an early
age that to be a connector,
and not having to ask for
anything in return and just,
I knew it would come back ten-fold,
and I wanted to be the guy
that could get anything done,
you know?
- [Gary] That was what
you wanted to stand for?
- I still do.
Anything, there's no
obstacle, there's no business,
there's no goal, there's no race.
- [Gary] So how much in playoff tickets
did you end up spending?
- Enough that it set me back.
- [Gary] Yeah!
- But again, those seats,
those seeds, you know
were planted, yeah, they paid off later.
- [Gary] So what happened next?
- So all of a sudden I was like, whoa,
as an entrepreneur, you guys,
we have a lot of
entrepreneurs in this room.
You realize that you look for something
to differentiate yourself.
And this was a big differentiator for me,
I was like, no one else
is doing sports music,
everyone is trying to be
Vanilla Ice at the time,
or whatever, but no
one's writing theme songs
for pro sports teams.
So that was my a ha moment,
and I started, I set up a
company to write theme songs
for other teams.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- And I'm like, I ended up
doing almost every team,
and then I sold that company to--
- In the NBA?
- NBA, and some baseball and football.
- What was the most next famous song?
- Well, what happened was, the
songs became somewhat popular
in each region, but I
turned it into selling them
as a compilation with all the songs that--
- That I understand,
but in its own region--
- Chicago, 'cause Jordan came back,
there was a song called
"Right Back In It."
But I sold almost a million units.
So it became a business,
and I sold that company
to a public company.
- And in that transaction,
did you make some money?
- Yes.
- Did you have to work
there for a little bit?
- I worked, we had an earn out,
so I worked there for a year and a half,
and then we hit the earn out, and--
- Talk to me about that year and a half.
- Well, in our contract, they paid us
a couple million dollars up front,
but we had a 16 million
dollar trigger if we hit
X amount in profit, so we
literally had a calendar,
we had three years to do it.
And I'm like, every day I was like,
you've got 364 more days, man!
We gotta hit this number!
Every day was a countdown, and
that's how I, I mean, and we hit it.
- So you're wildly
motivated, interest aligned?
- Yeah.
- You hit it, you're out.
What happens next?
Now you have some money.
- What happened next was--
- How old are you?
- I'm 20, at the time, maybe 26.
- And you have some money.
- Mm-hmm.
- Like way more than you ever had before.
- Yeah.
Anyone in my family.
- And, do you go crazy, do you
do dumb shit, what do you do?
- No, I mean,
my life was pretty simple,
it was pretty simple then,
and pretty simple now.
But I was still 26, 27 years old,
but what happened was, the
guy that bought our company
had a timeshare on a private jet.
And he invited me at 27 years old
on to his private plane, it was like
when I walked on it was like,
I don't know if you guys
saw "The Wizard of Oz,"
it was like the scene
in "The Wizard of Oz"
when everything goes from
black and white to color,
it's like, what?
People fly like this?
I was like, you gotta be kidding me!
I want to fly like this!
So by the time we landed,
my partner and I were like,
let's start a private jet company.
So we can fly on private
planes when we travel.
I was like, definitely!
Except we had no airplanes.
But we had an idea, and
we took that idea to--
- And who was that partner?
- His name is Kenny Dichter.
And we took that idea to--
- And how did you meet Kenny?
- Kenny, so I owned the trademark
to all these theme songs,
the songs that I was writing
for the sports teams were popular,
but the trademarks were more valuable.
So "Go, New York, Go" was
being used by Budweiser,
Foot Locker, all these big companies,
and I wasn't getting any money,
'cause I sold the song for four grand.
So I got smarter, and I
started licensing the song
and keeping the marks.
Kenny owned a clothing company,
so I'm like, we make "Go, New
York, Go" tee shirts and hats,
and we started working together.
And, you know, built a
big business out of it.
Then I was a guest, I'm like,
"Let's start a private jet company,"
he was like, "Definitely."
And we took a meeting with
a company called NetJets,
owned by Warren Buffett, the
largest private jet company
in the world--
- How did you get to that meeting?
- Crazy story, man.
The president of NetJets's
daughter had a sweet 16,
and Christina Aguilera was performing.
And through somebody that knew me,
and they knew that I knew the manager,
and called up and like,
"This guy wants something
special for his daughter."
And like I said, nothing's impossible.
I called up, and the
next day at the concert,
she was a background
singer with the mic off.
And he called me up, he was like,
"I don't know who the fuck you are,
or what you do, but my
daughter is a hero in our town.
If you ever need anything, let me know."
A year later, I need 650 airplanes.
Jim?
(laughter)
You remember Christina Aguilera story?
I'm like, that was me,
can I see you on Friday?
Friday comes, we go and
we have the meeting,
and it lasted about 12 minutes,
and the CEO, Rich Santulli, said
literally threw us out,
this is a direct quote,
and it really pissed me off, he said,
"If you think I'm giving two guys
who probably didn't break
1,000 on their SAT,"
which really pissed me
off, I got a 980 on my SAT,
so it really bothered me, he was like,
"That's never happening," he threw us out.
And then the president, Jim,
who I got his daughter hooked
up, grabbed me and said,
"That was unbelievable."
So we got thrown out
in 12 minutes, he goes,
"Santulli doesn't give anyone 12 minutes.
I believe in this, but bring it to life.
Come back next week."
So we came back next week,
and we realized, we could
never sell this idea
in a Powerpoint, 'cause this
guy sees 100 Powerpoints,
and entrepreneurs have to differentiate.
So we brought in our own focus group,
and we set up a table
by the board room table,
and one by one, we had eight people come,
Carl Banks from The New York
Giants, Run from Run-DMC,
a powerful female real
estate mogul in New York,
and one by one, they
stood up and they said
they'd never buy a fraction
what NetJets was selling.
But they'd buy a 25 hour jet
card, what we were offering.
(snaps fingers)
And he gave us a deal.
And a year later, we did five
billion dollars in sales.
- Then what happens?
- Then life changed.
The chips were purple,
and you know,
money's interesting, man.
It's interesting, we all
play for it, we all want it,
but we don't really even
know what we're playing for
or why we want it.
And then we get it, and it's confusing.
And my relationship, we
think of relationships
in terms of people, casual relationship
with your mom or your dad,
we don't think of relationships
in terms of money and time.
And I have a very good understanding
of my relationship with time,
I know you just posted that,
I've been talking about
that for a while, and money.
And all of a sudden, I
came into a lot of money.
And I was single.
And I had airplanes,
and I was in New York,
I could go on a date with this lady,
I'd be like, if it was
going good, I'd be like,
"You want to go to Canada?"
(laughter)
What do you want to do?
I mean, people are going to Studio 54,
trying to get to Studio 54, I'm like,
let's go to Hawaii tonight.
(laughter)
So I had a great decade.
- Fair enough!
And then what happened?
(laughter)
- And then I decided that
I didn't want to sell airplanes anymore.
That wasn't,
I didn't feel like,
I felt like I wanted to
make a quarter by myself,
than have 75 cents in
the company I was in,
I want to go out on my own.
So I was training for a hundred mile run,
I realized, I had signed
up for the USA National
Ultra Marathon Championship,
because you didn't have to qualify,
you could just send $50 registration
and you're in the national
championship, and I'm like,
I'm competing in the
national championship?
It's fuckin' unbelievable!
Then I Googled how do you
run a hundred mile race,
and it came back with a year,
everything came back with a--
- How did that even hit
your radar to enter?
Do you remember?
- I went through a crazy
period of time, man.
I was thinking about
giving all my money away,
I was thinking about charity,
I was just like,
I just, you know.
- You were just trying to figure it out.
- Trying to figure it out!
And I was like,
I want to do something big for charity.
And I didn't want to have a
bake sale or a golf outing,
my friends were all having foursomes,
I don't want to, I'm not a foursome guy.
So--
- The golf term, relax.
- Yeah, I'm gonna--
(laughter)
- Keep going.
Just trying to help the kids at home.
Go ahead.
- I wanted to run a hundred
miles without stopping.
- Yeah.
- So I like, and what
would be the biggest race
to do that in, for me it was
the national championship.
So I Googled it, it gave me,
everything was like a
year training program,
the race was in 90 days.
So I went from basically
couch to a hundred miles
in 90 days.
And during the training,
I did a lot of research
around hydration and nutrition.
And everything pointed at coconut water,
so I became the human guinea
pig for coconut water.
And like--
- What year was this?
- This was in 2006, 2006.
Because when you run a hundred miles,
how many calories do I
have to take in an hour?
How much sodium, how many
fluid ounces do I need?
Coconut water was the solution, so anyway,
I finished the race,
when I got to mile 83,
I had seven toenails
floating around in my shoe.
But I don't negotiate my goals.
We don't negotiate our goals in this room.
Whatever our goal is,
it's unwavering and the plot might change,
and the script might change,
but the goal doesn't change.
So my goal wasn't 87 miles, or 83 miles,
so I finished it, and then I was like,
this coconut water shit, man,
there's something to this!
By the way, I was in a
wheelchair for four days
after the race, but I did finish it.
And I spent a year trying
to figure out how to--
- Do you have photos of
you in that wheelchair?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You ever post it?
- Yeah.
- That's a good one.
- Yeah, I had a whole,
did a documentary on it.
- Go ahead.
- You know.
- Yep.
- Anyway, long story short,
I spent a year trying to figure out
how to import coconut water,
and I did get a 980 on my SAT,
'cause I couldn't figure
that shit out, man,
it was way over my head,
but I knew I could market it.
- Bro, I can't even spell coconut water.
- Right, okay, so you--
- I get it.
Keep going.
- You would have been
a great partner for me!
- Clearly!
- But I knew I could market and sell it,
so I partnered with a
company called ZICO, Z-I-C-O,
they were doing about
three million dollars
in sales at the time.
You know, one of the
things as an entrepreneur
is figuring out how to get
from point A to B the fastest.
You know?
And for me, the learning
curve was too great,
so partnering was the fastest way.
So I partnered with ZICO,
and two years later, we sold it to Coke.
And,
I got married,
I married an entrepreneur, my own,
my wife owns a company called Spanx,
which is a big deal here in the States.
- Sure is.
- And internationally too.
And that's where I am.
- And then what?
- I started shifting my life to--
- I'm thinking about changing
my show to "And Then What?"
Go ahead.
(laughter)
- I started focusing,
putting more on my plate
of the things that I love to do
with the people I love to do 'em with.
So my life shifted,
it didn't really shift,
'cause it's always been
this way, actually.
- You just put the energy
into a different bucket?
- The energy was actually always there,
but I started really
obsessing on experiences, and
just really obsessing on,
almost living a manic life.
- Is that how you ended up in
Atlanta, the Coke transaction?
- No, my wife's business is in Atlanta.
- Understood.
- But I shifted, after these
sales to really becoming
more experiential and
being intentional about--
- What year was the coconut water sale?
- 2013.
- Kay.
- Ish.
Yeah.
And the coconut water
deal was interesting,
'cause we were the first
company ever, I believe,
or at least publicly to
actually go to, again,
how do you get from A to B the fastest,
to go to influencers and
celebrities like Gisele
and Kelly Ripa,
Eminem, and take money in as investors
in exchange for equity
for doing more stuff,
like 50 Cent's got, 50 Cent got equity.
- Yep, in Vitamin--
- In Vitamin Water.
These guys wrote checks,
so it was really authentic.
- Yep.
- And customers are smart now, man.
They can see through endorsements.
So we had these real people
that really believe that,
real brand ambassadors,
and it worked.
And we sold it pretty fast.
And now I got four kids,
we're part owners of the
Atlanta Hawks, which you know.
- Yep.
- We live in Atlanta,
and I got a--
- Which is the epicenter
of culture in America.
- Yeah.
- Maybe the world, even for that matter.
- It's a really dynamic
time in Atlanta for me.
Just like, it's been
really fun to watch it
for the last decade,
it's just very clear to me
in importance of business,
because I think business
is a by-product of what
is established in culture,
popular culture in
America starts in Atlanta.
I really believe that.
- It's an amazing city.
- When I think about what hip hop
actually means to the world,
and where the innovation and,
it's just an, and then you
start layering in the tax breaks
that are now in place for Hollywood,
and just the Hollywood
infrastructure that's being built,
it's just a really
interesting time in Atlanta.
- Yeah, I feel fortunate
to be a part of it,
and I feel fortunate to have
been raised in New York,
because I think New York
gave me a lot of edge,
a lot of competitiveness, and
it helped me just get over my fear, man.
You couldn't, you'd get
swallowed in New York
if you were walking around scared.
- What do you think, what's, you know,
hearing that background and
a lot of people, you know,
hear that, it's obviously, you know,
I think this is what, you know,
we don't even really know
each other that that well,
and I think our relationship is so good,
because I think it's
bound on this intuitive,
creative entrepreneurial execution,
I think we have more
similarities than we don't,
but obviously we have differences.
What's the, it's what
leads me to this question.
Just hot take,
what are four to seven
observations that you think
are interesting right now
in the world through the
lens of entrepreneurship?
Like,
individual person, platform,
what somebody's doing,
what's on your radar--
- Well, I think--
- As a consumer of energy
around shit like this?
- I think that a lot of entrepreneurs
have been tricked into thinking
that things happen quickly.
And, you know, for me,
my journey was different,
and I remember going to Coke
when we had ZICO, and the
president of Coke said,
"It takes eight years to build
a brand in this country."
And I was like, eight years?
You know, I live in dog
years, everything's times,
so I'm like, eight years is forever!
And then I feel like every
year for me is four years,
literally the way I live my life.
So I feel like--
- That's in the speed of your execution.
- I just feel like I've done
200 years worth of stuff
in 50 years.
But I feel like entrepreneurs are,
feel like it's get rich quick,
and everything has to be quick,
and we try to cut corners,
and not all, but that's just
the vibe that I'm getting,
and 'cause we live in an
age of likes and insta
and fast and speed, and that's amazing.
But there's also, that
leads to disappointment,
it takes time, and that's okay,
to build the foundations
of a long-lasting business.
- I think what we've glossed over,
and you've touched on it
lightly with the tickets is,
a lot of your execution,
you know, what, (laughs)
it's really cool to get the
meeting with the jet company.
What's more interesting to me is,
why those really fancy people
would go to that meeting and sit there.
You built up equity through relationships,
which takes time
to be able to convert that
energy for that execution.
- Yeah.
Yes.
I mean also--
- Right?
- Yeah.
- I mean, why did,
why did Carl Banks and
Run and all these people,
why did they go?
- I'm gonna tell you why.
I'm gonna tell you why, 'cause
people buy into stories,
people, and momentum more than products.
- Always.
- So you're the business plan.
You're the business plan!
We had momentum, and we had a story,
and when you have a
story that's exciting--
- But even taking it for, yes.
But what I'm curious about is
buying the tickets on your credit card.
You're right,
how does one who's listening right now
get in front of the Carl Banks
and the Run of their day,
Gunna right now, get in
front of Gunna and Von Miller
right now for everybody who's listening,
is a disconnect, I want to go into that,
because I would argue the seed
of so much of this foundation
is within that.
- You put yourself in a position
where luck can find you.
You put yourself in a position
where you attract luck.
So when I was 21 years
old, man, I had nothing.
I wasn't broke, but I had nothing,
I was staying on couches.
My office was the Beverly Hills Hotel,
'cause I realized that if I
went to the Beverly Hills,
I was at 21 years old, I got
invited to a lunch meeting,
and I walked in, I'm like,
there's Russell Simmons, there's Lee Orr,
there's all these music moguls
and entertainment moguls,
and I'm like--
- This is where everyone is.
- You don't have to
have a room at the hotel
to come here for lunch, I was like, what?
I can buy an eight dollar salad
and sit here for 10 hours,
and I did, every day.
And that was my office.
And then people started recognizing me,
and then it was on me to attract them.
Hey, you're here again,
you look good, look at you,
whatever.
Just to get a face and now,
all of a sudden after six months,
I put myself in a position
where I could get a record deal,
where I could find somebody,
where I could call somebody,
where I could say, "Hey, can I
borrow you for five minutes?"
- Let me interrupt, I apologize.
- That's the name of the show!
- (laughs) Thank you very much!
(laughter)
What scares the fuck out of me is
how unbelievably true that is,
how an eight dollar salad for
that cost is the arbitrage,
and how somebody in Iowa that's listening
to this story right now
in the rural part of Iowa
has something 37 trillion
times more powerful
than your ability to be in
a place to pay eight dollars
for that salad,
which is called direct
messaging on Instagram.
What scares me to no end
is that people will spend 80
trillion hours on dwelling
and complaining and worrying
about what they don't have,
but we live in Bumblefuck, Iowa,
listen to these two right now,
and not realizing what they do have,
which is us two schmuck-o's,
with all our charisma
and all our this, still
didn't have something
called Instagram DM,
and the 21 year old you would
have stayed on that couch
and DM'ed for 19 fuckin' hours,
'cause you would have bled for it,
and then there would have been one yes,
and that is such a real story right now
for anybody listening, not
just people that happen to be
in city areas where
this shit could happen.
The serendipity of
creating that for you now
is literal, but people
then here me say that,
'cause I put out that content,
and they give up after
29 people that they DM,
and then they DM me
and they're like, Gary,
you're fucking full of shit,
I DM'ed a bunch of people,
I haven't gotten my music out there,
or sold my tee shirt.
I'm crazy, and I reply,
I'm like, hey, Carl,
with three followers, I'm like,
how many people have you DM'ed?
They're like, 29.
I'm like, go fuck yourself.
You sat there for fuckin'
12, 15 hours a day.
- I think, can I add on to that?
- You can do anything you want.
- So I think a lot of
people that send DM's
don't even actually know
how to send the proper DM.
- I agree.
- So people--
- By the way, real quick,
'cause I'm gonna add on to it,
there's been plenty of people
that went to the right places,
that lost.
- Oh yeah!
- You had the right tack
to start the conversation
with Russell Simmons,
it's my life, I'm on the
other end of this now.
It is fascinating to me
to watch people go with selfish behavior
in their one serendipitous moment
to get something to happen.
- When I write an--
- People roll up on me, I apologize,
99.999 percent of the time,
to tell me what I can do for them.
- Yeah.
It's the whole thing about this is like,
as entrepreneurs, there's
one rule of thumb.
We have to create value.
If you obsess on--
- As humans.
- Right.
If you obsess on value and wake up,
how can I provide value as a husband,
as a boss, or whatever,
in the long term, it's
gonna pay off, and--
- Always.
You won't have the ability to pick up
all the opportunities.
- Right.
One thing that I do that really helps me,
I ask myself a very simple question.
Would I recommend myself
as fill in the blank?
as a dad, as a CEO,
as a business partner, and
if the answer is no, why?
And what am I doing wrong?
When it comes to DM's,
I feel like people want to
know what's in it for me.
So when I write an email,
I could spend three hours on an email.
Sleep on it, review it, edit it,
how could I make it shorter,
is the caption punchier?
If I was the recipient,
how would I react to it?
It's not like just, oh,
I'm gonna DM, and boom.
It's like, how do I get
this person to respond
in the way that I want
the response to happen?
And I don't believe in--
- Real quick.
- Yep.
- And what we're painting for
everybody who's listening is,
look, the fuckin' internet
has given everybody an at bat.
It doesn't mean that
you can hit a fastball.
And so, the work you put
in to having the ability
to hit a fastball,
but the fact that we're now in a place
where everyone gets an at bat,
which was not the case pre-internet,
is bonkers, bonkers shit.
- You're a genius about
this DM thing, though,
because I got a lot of
layers to get to me.
I have my assistant, voicemail,
people screen my email,
but I check my own social.
So I actually, to your point,
now that you bring it up,
the guy that does all
my merch for my company,
29029, this race company
we have, DM'ed me!
And you know what he said?
He created a win-win.
I mean, I'm sorry.
He created a no lose.
Win-wins don't work,
because if I say a win-win,
you're talking about this too?
- No, no, I like where you're going.
- When you have a win-win,
Gary might win here,
and I might win here.
That's not a win-win.
That's a Gary's dominating the win.
A no-loses, oh.
There's no risk, I can't lose.
He sent me a DM and it said,
hey, send me your logo, I'll send you
a bunch of samples of
stuff, no cost, no risk,
no anything, if you like it,
I'd love a shot to work
with you, I'm like,
okay.
I sent it to him a day later,
I get a FedEx with this
amazing product line,
and I'm like, done.
Hundreds of thousands of dollars later.
- We talked about this earlier,
and it's great for everybody to listen,
it's about doing instead of talking.
People DM me all day long,
Gary, I want to work for you for free.
Okay, that's amazing,
if you think about it
that sounds win-win,
no lose is, Gary, I made this.
And then we look at it.
Our team looks at things that are made
with my content, we
99.999 percent of the time
don't even hear you when you
say you're gonna work for free.
- Yeah.
- Action,
always action.
- I invited,
I went to a dinner party with my wife,
and they went around the room,
and they asked everyone
to name three people
that were alive they'd
want to have dinner with.
And you came up, oh, Gary,
Buffett, this one, that one,
but when it came to me, all
three of mine were rappers.
And the reason was, I wanted
to meet the three people
that changed the course of my life
as a 14 year old kid
growing up in New York,
so at the end of the
dinner, I called my 10,
I invited the 10 most
influential artists in my life
to my house for dinner, and they all came.
- That's cool.
- I knew two of 'em,
and people were like, how
did you get Rakim, man!
How did you get Big Daddy Kane?
And I'm like, I asked them,
in a no-lose,
and they came.
People want to help people
- Yeah, it's really crazy, because again,
it's super important,
'cause I want to make sure
the listener gets value,
you've put up enough W's on the board,
and had enough social currency
to pull off that Hail Mary
which is amazing.
- You're right.
- On the flip side,
it's also how you got there,
because the 21 year old
you that had nothing
was willing to ask a hundred
people to get one yes.
- Yes.
- Okay, that's why I'm fired up.
So for everybody listening,
if you've put enough wins on the board,
you're probably more likely to get
seven out of 10 yeses than you think,
and for everybody who's
the 20 year old you and me
that nobody knows at
all or gives any fucks,
you will get a one out of 400.
How do I know that?
Because you and I are
exactly the characters
that say yes out of that 400
once every thousand times.
- I still do it!
- Me too!
Which is why I'm saying it again.
- Yeah.
- This is a very important conversation,
and because we grew up in the same era,
I shit on these entrepreneurs in this era.
You gave me the internet?
Fuck you!
This internet thing?
Fuck you, man!
First of all, would've definitely
not graduated high school.
And second of all,
I would have made some crazy shit happen.
You've got it so easy right now.
- Yeah, I mean, I remember when I,
just to that point, Gary,
when I was starting out at Marquis Jet,
I was looking for my first customer.
And I didn't have a database,
I didn't have a sales force,
I had no way to get leads.
The only way I could get a lead
was to show up where rich people were.
- What year was this?
- This was like in '99.
- Right.
- But I had to go where rich people were,
I didn't, we didn't have--
- You had a pager?
- A what?
- Did you have a pager in '99?
- I had a pager, I probably
had, but there was no--
- But you had that pager to act cool.
- I had to show up.
I couldn't, I didn't, I had no email list.
And I heard about this event called TED,
this conference called TED in Monterrey,
(Gary laughs)
California, and I'm like,
there's gotta be rich people at TED.
So I flew 16 hours, I connected
in Chicago, landed in LA,
drove five hours to Monterrey,
and I get to the event,
and I recognized immediately,
you can't get into TED
without a credential.
And I'm like, what, so ridiculous!
You need a credential?
So I just traveled 16
hours, I need a sale,
so I go to the coffee shop, and I
realize that every hour and a half,
people are coming in,
and they're ordering lattes and muffins,
'cause they're on break,
they have credentials,
they're on break at the conference,
and I'm like, so the next day
I showed up at the coffee shop, and I--
- You stole a fuckin'--
- No, I bought every
single muffin in the store,
I controlled all the muffin inventory
in Monterrey, California.
And the first break
comes, and the guy comes,
and was like, I'll have
a latte and a muffin,
the guy's like, you can have a latte,
but we're out of muffins.
He comes back out, I'm like,
so sorry, sir.
I overheard you, I actually have a muffin.
(laughter)
I have 450 muffins!
Would you want one, he's like,
well, he's like, no, no,
no, you can take one.
I says, well, what do you do?
We start talking, I said,
"I own a jet company,"
and he goes, "Get out of here!"
He's like, "I'm actually," and
this really happened to me,
"I'm actually in the
market for a private jet,"
he goes, "Do you mind if we sit down
and talk about it," I'm like,
"Mr. Qualified, you can sit
wherever you want to sit, man!
Absolutely!"
And he was my first sale.
Josh Kopelman from Half.com.
- Oh, I know Josh.
- And that's how my first sale--
- But like, but if you think about,
it's actually stunningly
unbelievable and wildly not,
it's incredibly practical.
You know who your customer is,
go there.
What pisses me off, and this
is why he's telling this story,
and it's an interesting take is,
that's amazing and epic
and iconic of a story,
you can lay in your fucking bed
and email and DM people.
What is the matter with people?
Back to nothing is impossible,
well, the internet has
made it uncomfortably easy.
And yet, people are losing?
Fuck you.
- I think it goes back down
to what I said earlier,
even deeper than the DM's Gary--
- Go ahead.
- Is negotiating your goals.
And I think you asked me
about entrepreneurship,
and I said, you know,
people want to get, happen
quicker and speed up the process
and this and that,
but I also think, it's easy
to negotiate your goals.
It's easy now to say, oh,
I'm not gonna do this,
I'm gonna try this, I'm gonna throw,
and people don't stick with things.
Most people do 95 percent
of the same thing.
- 'Cause they don't mean it, Jess.
They actually don't.
It sounds good.
There's a really deep psychology on this
that people have to wrap their,
and by the way, there's
nothing wrong with it!
Why do you want to be a billionaire?
Why do you want to start a business?
This is what goes into
a very deep conversation
which is, people do things
they think they're supposed to,
they don't mean it!
When you mean it,
there is no other option.
When you don't mean it,
because you think it projects well,
or it's the thing you should do,
or your parents want you to,
or you think it's cool,
or it'll get you girls,
or it sounds fun.
- The deeper layer of that,
the deeper layer of that, of meaning it,
comes from wanting it.
And I could say, if someone said to me,
what's the silver bullet
of being an entrepreneur,
I would say, you have to really want it,
and then people laugh.
I really wanted the promotion,
I really wanted to win the lottery,
they don't understand
what I'm talking about.
I could look at someone in their eye
and tell right away if
they want it or not,
if they're willing to go through
the 18 couches that I went through,
and I have plenty of egg on my face too!
You gotta want it so bad
that the obstacles don't mean anything.
So if you do 400 DM's and they don't hit,
it doesn't mean anything,
you're on DM one.
It starts with one--
- And you're really there,
you're almost evil about it,
and you're happy nobody replied.
Where I go is a scary place
where I'm like,
I hear that, I'm like, yeah.
I want disgusting.
I want, I mean it.
If I hit 400 DM's, and
it comes back goose egg,
I get crazy, I'm like, uh huh.
I'm like, you fuckers
are gonna be real sad
when you see this DM in six years.
- Yeah, it's fuel.
- It's real fuel, I'm on
some real chip on shoulder,
I'm gonna fuckin' kill your mother shit.
- Well, you--
(laughter)
- When it comes to business,
and real, no, I mean this!
- When it comes to everything.
- In real life, I don't
want to kill your mother,
but in business, I,
when I watch athletes play,
I love people that, I love Draymond Green.
That's who I am as an athlete.
Fuck you at all costs, I
don't give a fuck, fuck you!
- See, I think, I think it's everything,
because if you don't have that attitude
in other buckets of your life,
it's everything.
You have to create an
environment in your head
that no matter what,
you're gonna get it done.
- But real quick, and I,
'cause your part ownership
in the Hawks is a good comp,
I'm always fascinated by this.
You're on the field, football game, right?
It's a rough fuckin' sport.
You're breaking people's fuckin' faces,
triple zero, game over,
everyone comes to the middle,
and you're like, hey, how's Sarah been?
I actually feel that in my business life,
in the context of business,
I'm gonna break your ankle,
and I don't give a fuck, and fuck you,
and I want the whole crowd,
the reason I've become
friendly with Novak Djokovic
is I, he's one of the few
people I've reached out to ever,
because I'm like, motherfucker,
there is only one thing
I see on Earth right now
that I completely wish I could do,
which is be in center court at Wimbledon
against Roger Federer, and know
every fucker in that stadium
and everybody who's watching
is rooting for Federer.
When Novak goes into that zone,
when he's basically like fuck all of you,
I get crazy, I have hairs on
the back of my neck right now,
and goosebumps.
Novak, when he's against Federer,
in center court at Wimbledon,
like happened this year,
and the entire world is like,
"Let's go, Roger, let's go, Roger,"
when he hits a big shot
and everyone goes quiet,
the chemicals in my, all I want to do is
be in that moment, because
nothing excites me more
to look at every single
person in the crowd
of like, what's up with your boy, dick?
(laughter)
- Listen.
If there's one thing we agree on,
it's that that's the way I'm wired.
And I mean--
- What that does is it makes
you not be scared of losing.
You actually already set
it up to enjoy the losing.
- When I took my book,
"Living With a Seal"
to the publishers, I got 11 rejections.
And all it did was make me be like,
I can't wait.
- My brother A.J. and I have
a sports representation business,
we just went through a draft class, right?
We got a ton of no's.
When I tell you I can't
wait to see those fuckers
in real life in six years
and look them dead in the,
I'm already doing it,
'cause there's some kids
that said no three years ago,
that are already not doing as well
as they thought they were gonna do,
and their agents don't give
a fuck about them anymore,
'cause they're not gonna make any money,
and I would've fucking
taken care of them for life.
I look at them dead in the face and say,
you fucked up, dick.
- Listen.
Anger is a really--
- No, it's not anger!
- It doesn't sound angry to me, Gary.
- No, it's--
(laughter)
First you're gonna kill someone's mother,
then you're gonna-- (laughs)
- It sounds, no, no, I know, no, no,
it sounds wildly aggressive,
it's actually unbelievably
good oxygen for,
it's deep merit-based competitiveness.
- It is.
I think, listen.
I think you, whatever you have to pull,
whatever emotion you have to pull from,
people say get rid of your anger,
it's negative, anger to me is like fuel,
I need a little anger, you
know, it's fuel, I need it.
It's a hard thing to channel consistently,
and there's a nega, but you need it.
- It's funny, just to play out the story,
to give context, 'cause I think
all these things have layers,
it's funny, I'm not angry
at any of these kids,
I'm devastated for them.
Which then manifests me,
it's like this incredible,
all I want to do is have
dinner with the 11 people
that said no to your book and you.
And just sit, I love that shit.
I love, but I also like losing.
If you're gonna be that person,
you also have to be the
person that when you're wrong,
you're like, man, you saw
it, I didn't fuckin' see it,
I'll take that L.
It's why I love sports, bro.
You win and lose,
entrepreneurship's hidden right now.
Accu-hires, fake headlines,
it's just not sports.
- Right.
- 182 to 79, that's what it was.
You know?
- Yeah, I mean, you can use
bank accounts as scorecards
and that kind of thing.
- You can, but there's a lot of hiding.
There's a lot of manipulation in that,
we're just, you're watching every,
I wish everybody recorded
every single action,
then you could see it more,
because that's what sports is,
we're watching all of
them, all the minutes.
- I think also at the end of the day,
we can talk about this
as a great conversation,
you know, going back to your
question about entrepreneurs
and what I see, at the
end of the day, man,
we humans, we all want the same thing.
What do you think the one
thing that we all want is?
- I think it's happiness.
- Exactly, we want to be happy.
So if you're happy,
all for it, you know?
Things make people, different
things make people happy,
people are driven by different things.
- When you said "My dad's
a family man, plumber,"
you know, I was like, so awesome.
'Cause I know that!
I know so many, people that,
to your point, there's
7,000 ways to be happy,
this is about self-awareness
of how you tick,
not how you think you should tick.
- My brother asked me,
I have a, my son is a swimmer,
he's young, 10 years old,
and my brother asked me how
my son was doing in swim,
and I said, you know,
he's doing really good,
but he doesn't have the eye of the tiger.
- Yeah.
- And he's a great swimmer,
but just doesn't have,
my brother said, "That's
okay, as long as he's happy."
- Yep.
- And I'm like, no.
My son would be happy playing Minecraft
and eating Haagen-Dazs every day,
and Fortnite on the couch.
That's not what I want.
I want him to be, to
live up to his potential,
and I don't see how anybody on--
- But is that a different framework than
where your parents went about it?
I'm just curious, 'cause it
was interesting to hear you,
when you just said that, I
went back to the beginning
of this podcast, thinking
about the freedom
your parents gave you,
and were they into the guiding aspect,
is that why you run a
basketball team or not?
I'm just curious.
- Their potential,
so when I look at myself,
and I'll answer it this way.
I don't want to be the
80 percent version of me.
Right?
I don't want to grow up and be like,
okay, you could've been
built Vayner to this,
but you only took hit here or whatever.
- But that's you within yourself--
- I understand.
- You know?
My parents, their scorecard
was how they raised their kids.
That's what made them happy,
and my mom's whole life,
I remember going to this
grocery store and someone, my
mom got into a confrontation,
I'm like, I can't believe
my mother even has
a life outside of our family,
that she would even react like this.
Their whole life was
about building my family.
- Yep.
- That was it, that's
what made them happy.
- Yep.
- My life is bigger than that.
Not in a bigger difference,
it's just got more buckets, it's wider.
So for my family, that's
their, happiness to them,
was taking care of their
kids, putting them in college,
giving 'em a car.
- I got it.
- And for me, it's,
I want a number one,
my standards are high, man.
I don't want to write a
book, I want a bestseller.
- But do you want to impose
that on your children,
so for me--
- My children--
- For me, when you went there, I'm like,
I have no interest in my kids'
taking on my characteristics
in any shape or form,
I just want them to be in love
and respect their characteristics
as much as I do mine.
- That's fantastic.
- Yeah.
And I, to your point, every
does stuff their own way,
I'm just curious where
you're going with it.
- My kids are on their own journey,
and because I used to play basketball
'til midnight every night,
and my son wants to play Fortnite,
I can't tell him to go play basketball.
They're on their own journey.
But I do want them to live
up to their potential.
I just sat with a financial advisor,
and he said to me, "What would
you rather give your kids?
A boatload of money, or a
boatload of life experiences?"
I want my kids to experience
and see what they like.
- On their terms or yours?
- On both,
I want to, no, I want to
give 'em the opportunity--
- It's amazing, by the way,
first of all, while
we're talking about this,
'cause a lot of people are listening,
I have 0.00 interest in
ever getting into anyone's
actual personal way of parenting,
'cause that's, everyone's
got their own uniqueness,
and they should.
I love the macro
conversation of this game,
because where I go into this is,
kids are living in a reality
that is intuitive to
where their world is going
versus the world we came from.
I think so much about
eSports for that reason,
it's changed in the last 24 to 36 months,
but the demonization of parents,
I mean, you're not doing
that, but I'm just,
I'm using this as an example,
there are a ton of parents out there
who have taken their kids out of the path
of becoming all time great
professional eSports players,
because they've deemed
that not being a thing,
and I think about that every day.
- My parenting's a work in progress, guys.
I'm figuring it out as
I go, I don't, you know,
I have four kids, they're all under 10.
- I'm curious about Fortnite all day
and Haagen-Dasz as actually
being the stepping stone
to actually winning.
To actually getting full fulfillment.
I really believe that.
I'm debating it for myself,
I'm fascinated by that.
Because I, and it sounds
like you too for that matter,
I didn't do anything that
gave people confidence
that I was up to something.
When I was 11, I was doing
everything off the reservation.
I was an immigrant kid,
everybody had to get good grades,
I was getting F's.
I never clicked into wanting
good grades for myself.
I clicked into, this is all horseshit.
And I always wonder, what
are the 10 and 12 year olds
thinking right now that we can't see,
and I feel like some of 'em
are exactly where I was,
and I think about that.
- Listen.
Again, I think
I can only speak for myself,
and just so you guys know,
my kids have glitches just
like your kids have glitches.
- Everyone's got glitches.
- You know, it's like, you think oh,
you sold a company, or it's like,
I have the same, my kids don't
get out of the carpool line
'cause they have anxiety.
The same kind of stuff
everybody deals with.
And I don't know, I just know that
I want to give 'em as much opportunity--
- Yeah, honestly, you'll appreciate this,
I'm not even taking--
- I want 'em to be 10.
- I want to take even the four of them
out of the equation.
I just think you're a creative thinker,
and it's just an interesting
conversation for me.
You know, just I think we're
at an interesting time,
I think people are in deep shit
in thinking they know
where the world's gonna be
in 15 to 20 years.
When I think about what 5G is
gonna do as an infrastructure,
and what that opens up,
you've got fuckin' Elon
Musk today talking about
living on Mars, people are like,
people don't get it.
We FaceTime people in fuckin' China,
and it costs zero dollars,
the people that were
making decisions for us
didn't have phones that got off a wall.
It's fuckin' crazy out here.
And it's about to get wildly crazier.
You think technology's advanced now?
This is dogshit, this is a fuckin' pager.
- I agree.
- I know you agree.
So,
we're imposing today's reality
against kids that are
gonna live in a world
that's 15 years from now,
looks nothing like today,
and we must hedge for that
in when we think about shit.
- Gary for president.
(laughter)
- But you know what I mean?
It's an, it's fun.
I know that makes sense to you.
- Yeah.
- The by-products of that.
- Yeah, it's interesting.
- One kid's talking about rap in 1985
in fucking Long Island,
rap wasn't even a fucking genre to people.
It was a fad.
Rock and roll.
The internet was a fad.
People laughed at my fuckin'
father when I launched
an e-commerce wine business.
The internet was a fad.
Fuck TikTok and Vine,
the whole fuckin' thing was a fad.
Do you understand what's coming?
Fuck!
(laughter)
Parting shots, what do
you want people to know?
You've got a lot of people listening.
- First of all, I want to
thank you for the opportunity,
this is super cool, I've
been wanting to do this
for a long time, you know,
we connect once in a while,
but it's good to sit with you.
- It's good to see you too.
- I'd like to arm wrestle you.
- How's VaynerSpeakers going?
Okay, we'll do that.
(laughter)
How's--
- Pay per view!
- How's VaynerSpeakers going?
One thing that everybody should know is,
I think you guys saw, about 16 months ago,
we started VaynerSpeakers.
I teamed up with my
agent at CA, Zach Nadler,
he's now the CEO of that.
It's been really fun,
he's actually in the room
while we're talking.
And one of the key targets for us
was Jesse, because we were
looking at things that,
arbitrage, who is way
better than people realize
at this exact second,
they are at this thing,
so it's exciting that you're with us,
straight talk, 'cause that's
what I love about you,
how's it going?
- It's been great, Zach's been amazing.
I was hesitant to do it,
'cause I was getting--
- Talk about it.
- Yeah, so I mean, just so you guys know,
I started speaking about three years ago,
I wrote a book, the book became
a number one best seller,
it was amazing, but it launched me
in a completely different
direction than I anticipated.
I started getting asked to speak.
And the first speaking event I went to,
there were 40 people, no microphone,
the guy said to me,
speak loudly and slowly,
you have 45 minutes.
And that has led to, you know,
much bigger stages,
and I did it all myself for two years,
and then Gary texted me and said,
I don't know if you remember this,
"I'm starting this thing."
And you know, I saw you speak,
you were great or whatever,
and introduced me to Zach, and--
- What goes through the process,
why am I--
- The process--
- I get so much inbound myself,
what do you think about it?
- The process for me was, you know,
can I do this myself, I'm doing it myself,
and it was, became an
easy decision for me,
because I fell in love with Zach,
and you know, you hand picked Zach,
and what you guys do at VaynerSpeakers,
and I weighed it all,
and it became super simple for me,
and it's just been a really good process.
Listen, after I sold my last business,
I'm like, I'm never having partners again.
- Right.
- I don't want partners, I want freedom.
- Right!
- You work so you get freedom.
- Correct.
- And I have a partner with,
partnership with you guys.
And it's been really, it's
been really good, and I'm--
- What's been the most surprising thing?
I like earning.
- It's just, there hasn't been
much of those big surprises,
it, you know, you guys laid
out exactly what it was been,
and it hasn't, we've been able to--
- The surprises that you could deliver--
- You actually did for the first time,
this is what we're gonna
do, and we're gonna do it.
And when I was disappointed
in certain things--
- Yep.
- I would say to Zach,
I want something bigger,
I need more, and you know,
and he would respond, so,
yeah, it's been real--
- You like it?
You like speaking?
- I love it.
- Yeah, me too.
- I wouldn't do it if I didn't like it.
- Yeah, I understand.
- Yeah, as you get older, man,
it's like,
you only have two buckets, Gary.
You've got aggravation versus reward.
And I want low aggravation
for the most amount of reward.
If something's high aggravation,
even high reward, I'm not doing it.
And you guys have made it low aggravation.
- You know what's funny, Jess?
If you, I, and many others
can get people to realize,
you don't have to wait
to 50 and some success
to put yourself in a position for that,
and you can actually do that at 22,
you'll just have to be a little patient,
and a little more humble,
but you could be way happier,
you and I in a lot of ways did do that,
which is what I think led to this,
and I think a lot more people can do it,
but they have all these expectations of
what they're supposed to do from 22 to 30,
and it fucks them up.
- It's true, and just to
add on about the speaking,
'cause I just, you know,
I talked about walking in
and speaking in front of 40 people,
and then, you know, as entrepreneurs, man,
it's okay to start small.
And I just want to say--
- The first, oh, go ahead, I'm sorry.
- It's okay to start
small, you start small,
you think big, you scale it fast,
something my wife always
says, you start small,
think big, and scale it fast.
And that's the way we've
been able to do it,
it feels really authentic and grass roots.
- When I wanted to get into tech,
the first five public things,
meet ups, events I did,
this is in 2009 when Wine Library had gone
from three to 60 million,
the first five things I did
was cold email conferences
in the tech world,
and offer to set up a table and pour wine,
I was a bartender
at the first, a Robert Scoble Jaiku event,
a technorati conference, I literally,
the first five events, I
found a picture of me and A.J.
Recently at a tech cocktail event in,
which was a D.C. meetup, I was the help.
That was after real success,
most people don't have
the humility to do that
with no success.
- Yeah.
That's what it is.
- 18 couches.
- 18 couches, brother!
- I love you, brother.
- Thank you.
- Thanks for being on.
Let's clap it up for Jess.
(applause)
I think 18 couches could be a real,
I think 18 couches could
be a real framework
for either a book or a talk,
because I really think,
and you saw I zoned in on it,
I think if you can go deep,
and the way that I've gotten
deep into fear and insecure,
if you go deep into the network you built,
which then became the foundation
of everything you've pulled off,
and the pattern recognition
of human arbitrage,
when you over-deliver and
you ask for less in return,
I think there's a real
unlock there for you,
and I think the framework of 18 couches
could be a really cool starting point.
- Yeah, and the mindset of me
when I was on 18 couches was,
I'm a millionaire, they
just haven't paid me yet.
That's how I was thinking.
That's how I was thinking, it was--
- Bro, I've owned the
Jets for a long time.
- Right, exactly.
That's a tough, that's
a tough one, though.
- I'm gonna pull it off.
(laughter)
- Thank you, brother.
- Real pleasure.
- [Jesse] Okay, man.
- [Gary] Cool.
Awesome.
(applause)
All right.